não é difícil
nós percebemos que a nossa sociedade da
qual nós fazemos parte
ela está fragmentada
não é difícil as evidências tanto de
corrupção quanto de violência quanto de
volúpia são claras
da mesma forma não é difícil nós
verificarmos que o ser humano também
está fragmentado através das diversas
manifestações e demonstrações quer seja
de medo culpa e apego ora vivemos com
muita ânsia de medo hora nos sentindo
muito culpados ou mesmo apegados a bens
materiais ou mesmo a pessoas e não é
difícil com isso concluir que a
fragmentação social
ela é fruto da fragmentação individual
portanto nós seres humanos somos de fato
o centro o cern
o ponto alto da questão
o nosso convite portanto é de centrarmos
a partir de agora toda a nossa atenção
em nós mesmos porque tudo sai de dentro
de nós e o que está aí fora é fruto do
que está aqui dentro
neste sentido importa nos muito
aprofundada acerca de nós mesmos
sobretudo no conhecimento e o
reconhecimento das nossas dimensões
nós temos
a missão do sentir a dimensão do pensar
e temos a dimensão do agir da dimensão
do agir
nós já sabemos muito dá a dimensão do
pensar
nós precisamos dia a dia educar a nossa
mente é educar os nossos pensamentos sim
e na dimensão do sentir o nosso desafio
é de buscarmos entender momento a
momento cada vez mais a nossa origem
causal a nossa origem primeira
primordial onde reside o sentimento e é
de fato ele o sentimento quem define o
pensamento qual nosso desafio não é
outro é uma vez lembrando que os outros
me cochito como certrim um composto de
sentir pensar e agir
não me permite por exemplo agir de forma
mais fragmentada usando apenas uma parte
de mim
eis que importa nos por demais darmos
atenção plena a possibilidade de
vivermos de acordo com a equação da ação
integral sim porque ela nos convida a
estarmos em permanentemente equilíbrio
integrando mesmo o nosso sentir o nosso
pensar é o nosso agir
se nós construímos conhecimento apenas
com base no agir e não pensar nós vamos
ter por exemplo dificuldade de sentir as
benesses ou não de nós lançarmos por
exemplo a bomba atômica na população
pensemos juntos sobre isso
é preciso portanto investimos num outro
processo de educação não basta nós
educarmos os nossos estudantes com
cultura material com
ciência dia exterior idade que envolve
intelecto
isso é bom mas isso não é o bastante
precisamos ea lei não é suficiente
vocês sabem por que vocês passaram por
isto como eu passei que não é suficiente
nós estudarmos língua portuguesa
matemática história geografia assim
precisamos e à lei precisamos ir além
precisamos incluir no nosso processo
educativo cultura e espiritual ciência
de interioridade que envolve as virtudes
e as competências sócio emocionais que
envolve o sentimento sentimento é mesmo
a palavra de ordem gente nós estamos
precisando investir nisto em sentimento
não temos mais tempo de fazer o
contrário disto
vocês hão de convir comigo não e em
função disto acreditando nisto é que nós
temos uma proposição muito clara de
podermos incluir na educação formal três
novos componentes curriculares que são
meditação consciência e autoconhecimento
os nossos educandos precisam ser a eles
oferecido essa oportunidade de despertar
o seu sentir a ponto de não mais serem
fomentadores de conflitos individuais e
ou sociais e acreditando nisto fizemos a
partir de nós mesmos e então há 23 anos
atrás nós criamos instituições
educativas onde os nossos estudantes têm
essa experiência direta e já temos
resultados cabais da sua importância
nós criamos ananda escola e centro de
estudos que oferece educação infantil e
ensino fundamental
nós criamos o
o instituto a nanda que oferece o ensino
médio há 15 anos e nós criamos o isel
instituto superior de educação ocidente
que oferece cursos de graduação e pós
graduação há 11 anos
nós somos nascemos como marco da nova
humanidade essa é a nossa missão
diferente disso seria pouco que a nossa
consciência inclusive não permite
pois bem quanto à especificidade da
prática da meditação para compartilhar
com todos vocês
as nossas crianças meditam desde os dois
anos de idade gente pensei o que é isso
as criaturas que não sabe muitas vezes
nem se comunicar direito na exterior
idade mas sabem se comunicar já na
interioridade é bonitinho de ver eu
convido vocês a perceber de perto essa
experiência
se nós aqui ainda não acreditamos vai o
nosso convite que começamos hoje à noite
ainda temos tempo mas nós já temos
provas cabais substânciais a ciência já
mostra o valor real da meditação
a meditação ela é que vale é o valor de
uma musculação para os nossos músculos
quando nós fazemos exercícios na
musculação faz isso com o sesi com os
músculos ea meditação faz isto com a
nossa mente
ela prepara a nossa mente para o que ela
deve e necessita fazer agora não basta
falar sobre isso importa sente e como é
que eu vou sentir só se praticar então o
convite é da prática por isso precisamos
expandir para que as nossas crianças
cresçam já com habilidade de sentir que
elas não precisem sofrer para buscar
suas interioridades sentença não pois
bem
a meditação todo o planeta já reconhece
o seu valor e os grandes iluminados
praticaram meditação
todos eles praticar meditação e com isso
demonstraram para toda a humanidade
ainda demonstra até hoje através dos
seus feitos dos seus exemplos que é
possível nós temos um viver cada vez
mais equilibrado a ponto de onde você
estiver
você se a luz de transformação para
todos ao seu redor
a nossa responsabilidade é inpa
a nossa responsabilidade é sinequanon
efe nominal e saber que nós somos a
pessoa mais importante porque o que sai
de me transformar em realidade a
humanidade isso é por demais relevante
coisa de percepção poder vir pra dentro
perceber isto que está à disposição e
agir com base nisto
diante dessa qualidade decente fruto da
meditação fica fácil se uma pessoa vier
por exemplo querer discutir comigo eu
poder fazer como jesus cristo nos
ensinará orai e vigiai e daí eu vou dar
muita atenção a mesma muita atenção a
ela a esta pessoa e com certeza eu vou
conseguir perceber o que ela está
sentindo e ao perceber eu vou poder
ajudá la a ponto de talvez aquele motivo
da discussão se dissipar não tem mais
razão
com isso eu ajudo na transformação
daquela pessoa que está comigo e com
certeza de todo o ambiente ao redor
estamos falando da possibilidade de nós
sermos agentes transformadores e
fomentadores de equilíbrio gente social
eis porque precisamos investir mesmo e
meditação precisamos precisamos investir
no mínimo uma hora por dia eu não
consigo fazer menos que isso mas quem
puder fazê lo eu recomendo é que eu
posso recomendar mais importa por demais
além da meditação nós recomendamos o
estudo dá
consciência nas nossas escolas sim
estudar a consciência pressupõe se
implicar com o trabalho que envolve leis
universais que nós já conhecemos
bastante
temos o exemplo de isaac newton isaac
newton com a sua máxima da ação e reação
nos ensinar a que toda ação provoca uma
reação igual e em sentido contrário ao
nosso desafio é nós podemos ensinar isso
as nossas crianças desde pequenas desde
a tenra idade a estudar é este assunto
no campo do comportamento humano para
além do campo da física isso nós
ajudaremos por demais a elas sob pena
das crianças ainda estarem a ouvir de
seus pais que não aprenderam sobre isso
por exemplo filho se alguém lhe bater
bata de volta
não sei se alguém aqui já ouviu isso se
levanta a mão quem já ouviu isso propôs
bem
além disso eu poder ouvir de um pai
dizer se você chegar acompanhado em casa
você vai apanhar duas vezes não não eu
estou ensinando intolerância gente isso
é falta de sentimento coisa que a nossa
consciência não permite mais a nossa
proposição portanto é sermos específicos
e diferentes graus de abordagem
obviamente nós oferecemos portanto
iniciação à consciência para a educação
infantil ensino fundamental consciência
no ensino médio e consciência elogia no
ensino superior em nível de graduação e
em nível de pós graduação lato e stricto
sensu mestrado e doutorado e obviamente
temos a noção de que um ser humano que
se implica e busca despertar seu
sentimento através do estudo da
consciência ele vai conseguir ter um
viver mais equilibrado com ele mesmo
portanto com todas as pessoas ao seu
redor é bem próprio da consciência
agora é um caminho sem volta posso dizer
vocês portanto se implicando com ela não
tem mais como desistir que bom que já
entramos nessa sala
que bom que nós já estamos aqui juntos
eles entendem que estou falando
pois bem quem se implica e quem investe
em meditação
quem estuda sobre consciência como eu
fiz comigo mesma no campo do
comportamento humano fiz e faço não vai
ter dificuldade em investir no que nós
chamamos auto conhecimento vai ser
simples vai ser fácil vai ter gosto por
estudar autoconhecimento
do contrário diante das tentações
pressões e ou provocações da vida ao
invés de nós irmos para dentro para nos
autoconhecer não eu vou pra fora e brigo
mais ainda e criou mais conflito ainda
sabe mas obviamente que não é tentado
pressionado eu provocado no dia-a-dia do
viver
nós passamos por isso porque por que não
damos conta de fazer todas as coisas que
temos para previstas naquele dia e
repressão
eu sou tentado a comer algo que meu
organismo necessita tentação e eu sou
provocado no dia-a-dia das relações
sobretudo dentro de nossos lares em
primeira mão onde através das relações
eu tenho condições eu sou o outro mostra
que eu sou eu mostro pra ele que os quem
ele é e tudo daí flui provocação
então o convite é nós investimos por
demais nisto que me favorece ver tudo
que tenham e aperfeiçoar o que sou
lembrando da máxima de que não é o
autoconhecimento não tem relação direta
com instrução
o ignorante não é de fato aquele ser
humano que é
não se instruiu não o ignorante é aquele
ser que não investiu ainda em
autoconhecimento
tal como o ser humano que fez a bomba
atômica
vocês acham que quem criou a bomba
atômica era analfabeto
obviamente que não obviamente que não
pelo contrário ser que por demais
desenvolver o intelecto mas com carência
de sentimento
eis a importância do auto conhecimento e
nós viemos laborando com isto desde a
percepção de que era preciso fazer
alguma coisa e não tinha um lugar melhor
para tratar destes assuntos senão o
espaço da educação e como nós estamos
falhando muito com isto precisamos
trabalhar de forma intensa para isto não
mais se reproduzir socialmente e com
esta clareza de fato nos implicamos com
proposição de meditação consciência e
autoconhecimento nas nossas instituições
escolares e em função disto e obviamente
vocês hão de convir comigo que a nossa
trajetória partiu lado os meus 12 anos
de idade onde eu já comecei a elaborar
sistematicamente a cerca de reflexões
que versavam sobre a minha existência
sobre a existência dessas crianças sobre
a existência da humanidade da sociedade
e com isto criei também neste tempo a
fundação acidente que a organização
científica de estudos materiais naturais
e espirituais
esta organização é a mantenedora das
nossas três instituições educativas que
já citamos e convidamos a todos também
para conhecê-la
qual é o nosso intuito é simples
o nosso intuito é podermos construir o
novo ser humano é nós podemos construir
o marco
da nova humanidade é nós podemos
construir o ente consciente e você você
já se percebe como este consciente e não
trabalhemos mãos à obra vamos juntas
obrigada
[Aplausos]